à quelques minutes du départ thierry
prend l'air au jardin aujourd'hui il
rentre chez lui pour faire du vélo matin
je me suis levé j'ai dit qu'un ça serait
bien de faire ça puisqu'on doit faire
les 24 heures fin août et je pense que
c'est fortement compromis
et donc j'ai dit pourquoi pas et faire
les 24 heures confinée après tout c'est
faisable
les 24 heures du mans vélo sur le
circuit bugatti avec les coureurs de son
équipe de châteauroux nous ils ont déjà
participé cinq fois pour ce défi confiné
ils seront deux équipes de 5 à
s'affronter
chacun chez soi on va faire comment 24
heures voilà on va pédaler à peu près
une heure à chaque achat crowley et
voilà moi je vais partir à trois heures
et je vais repartir à 20 eur puis à une
heure 6 heures et encore 11 heures
jérôme son adversaire est prêt donc je
vais passer plus ou moins 24 heures dans
le langage puisque je me suis aussi
installé un petit écoute crète pour
pouvoir sauter de molly couchette mon
vélo pendant ces 24 alors ces 24 heures
de confinement dans mon garage
à moins de deux kilomètres karine et
yanis son prêt devant la webcam e
pédaleront contre thierry balle est
sortie en campagne sur nos belles routes
oui ça me manque un peu oui ça c'est sûr
voilà s'adapte ça occupe
ça change un peu des deux toutes les
journées qui commençait à se ressembler
quoi finalement c'est sympa bon thierry
roule à 50 km heure il espère avec son
équipe battre le record qu'il avait
réalisé en 2015 sur le circuit bugatti
du mans 2 933 km pour l'instant ils ont
déjà gagné une bonne chose
un chouette moment de convivialité tous
ensemble en plein confinement